aujourd'hui les garçons vous marquer
l'histoire l'histoire de france première
équipe française qualifiée pour une
ligue des champions c'est du jamais vu
beaucoup de valides dans leur vie le
jour pas une ligue des champions vous
allez la jouer paul sur le papier ça va
être compliqué mais on est costaud et on
sait qu'on va aller au bout de cette
aventure tous ensemble manchester city
c'est pas une petite équipe notre équipe
italienne n est pas petit aussi on va
jouer contre les champions d'europe
ils sont professionnels ces joueurs-là
idia leur vie tous les jours pour taper
le ballon
aux billets d'avion les appuyer nous
mêmes les boissons l'eau on l'appelle
nous mêmes le tout est structuré mais ce
qu'ils ont peut-être pas et qu'on a nous
c'est ce qu'on a ici dans le coeur parce
qu'on n'a pas fait le déplacement pour
rien et garçons et cette ligue des
champions on va pas dire peut-être qu'on
va la prendre et pourquoi pas mais on va
marquer l'histoire et on va faire les
plus beaux matchs je vous ai posé la
question si demain vous prenez une
gélule et vous avez la jambe qui
repousse est-ce que vous acceptez cette
jambe aujourd'hui on vous l'a refusée
parce qu'on est aujourd'hui
catégoriquement si demain tu as cette
chance d'avoir cette jambe nabil ça tu
dirais non warhem si j'ai la jambe du
cndd bolt j'en voudrais même pas
le coach est très fort c'est un sacré
orateurs enfin cet orateur le doigt
quand ils partent dans l'ue deux côtés
étaient les critères
on est venu pour celle-là
mal à gagner coiffard
alors écoutez scène pour chanter
[Musique]
spéciale dédicace à tous les joueurs de
l'olympique jules moutier ouais je
balance les flots ne sais pas je viens
de padam frère comme la plupart des m6
les gens parlent de moi frère j'espère
que nous allons passer une super ligue
des champions avec nabil avec celle ue
avec tous les joueurs d'olympic jules
motif je vous dis à + sur canal + à
demain sur tf1 un maximum de bruit pour
l'olympique jus moutier
[Applaudissements]
à la tension a monté un petit petit à
petit plus on se rapproche de leurs plus
l'adrénaline monte mais c'est tout bénef
mois pour moi c'est c'est quelque chose
que je recherche en fait cette pression
c'est très très nalinnes de préparation
d'avant match
marchons
à huawei
yvan
en mode
non
moi je me suis fait amputer en 2010 et
j'ai découvert tout en foutez en 2014 en
faisant un stage de ski avait quelques
joueurs amputé qu'ils aient du football
ils ont bougé n'est pas trop mauvais
niveau sportif qui m'ont proposé de
participer ça m'a permis de retrouver
une estime de moi après l'amputation je
me suis dit ça va être compliqué de se
refaire certaines choses et le foot m'a
permis d'avoir un rythme un cadre
sportif qui me booste le quotidien en
fait
45 jours
afin de laisser une bonne image c'est le
plus important et puis après advienne
que pourra comme on dit
aujourd'hui où la faune on affronte les
italiens dans un premier temps donc le
sport c'est l'italien est juste après
les tubes sûr que je sais pas comment sa
peine est en tout cas c'est très
compliqué pour nous ça fait sûr pour eux
le savaient trop de problèmes de santé
nous on a tous dans l'équipe on l'a en
amont à des médias qui ferait le marché
l'école on a déjà goûté aux saveurs de
vie
confie la star le beau gosse de l'équipe
regardez juste jouer un match de foot il
se prépare comme si que la leur vol de
nuit benoît faut dire les choses c'est
pas grave
on va tout donner c'est aussi
jamais imaginé que je vais jouer la
ligue des champions
on l'a fait
c'est grâce à cet handicap je suis fier
maintenant on va réparer
[Musique]
voilà là vous êtes dans le match hors
progressivement comme l'a dit stéphane
tout à l'heure je compte sur vous 1 les
garçons pour vous donner à fond sur le
terrain on n'a rien à perdre soit
compétition on n'a rien à perdre allez
les gars ont encore sept minutes on va
être comme les 300 face à 1000 personnes
on doit les des spartiates aujourd'hui
des vrais spartiates aux pieds
[Applaudissements]
les règles donc c'est un football à 7
le gardien il est valide des jambes et
il lui manque un bras il peut attacher
son bras les béquilles sa accessoires
pour courir sur le terrain
il n'y a pas de hors jeu voilà et on
peut pas utiliser des béquilles si on
tape sur une béquille dans la surface ya
penalty ça très très proche du foot
valide du coup c'est pour ça que ça
s'est énormément développé à l'étranger
et l avantage de ce football là c'est
que on nous met pas assis sur des
fauteuils où on regroupe les handicaps
c'est un handicap spécifique aux amputés
des jours au mois mais trop décembre des
moyens grenu solo
[Musique]
plus près plus presse jiji tu es loin de
lui nabil intérieur intérieur vous
rentrer à l'intérieur même villa doit
renoncer le corps maintenu au
deuxième quand j'ai tout cinq ans
c'est bien
premier match je dirais de l'histoire
l'outil en ligue des champions ont fait
0-0 face une très belle équipe italienne
il aurait pu gagner comme on aurait pu
gagner on s'est créé des occasions on
affronte juste derrière l'équipe
favorite championne d'europe les dures
qu on va voir ce qu'on peut faire
comme un toolkit jeu de statut
mais où des
grèves en intérêts au gabon c'est
nico et orange aux carnets de copies
nature non oui mais non non c'est
l'arbitré cadeau cadeaux cadeaux
guelassimov ya jamais plus ma fille
jamais malgré ce guide le problème le
problème non non non problème non non
non non non non non non ok no problem
excuses m'excuse mais
eagle grave mais c'est drôle c'est drôle
il égale
et évite tellement le truc hein faut que
l'équipe en fait c'est pour ça que tu es
comme ça
je suis un passionné moi j'aime le balo
d'accord allez je vous alimente les
garçons je suis vraiment fier
aujourd'hui moi je vote morphine
d'accord
[Applaudissements]
c'est les champions d'europe on pouvait
pas s'est défendu comme on l'appelait et
la télé polonaise aussi à c'est bien
tout le monde qui vous regardent et
extraordinaire soyez fiers de ce que
vous avez fait aujourd'hui parce que
nous on est des petits lcd ganser des
champions d'europe on n'a pas à rougir
face à ça et vous pouvez vous applaudir
les garçons
[Applaudissements]
voici juste une sphère fait de les voir
une fierté parce que ils ont tous des
histoires de vie ces garçons-là cette
île des champions et là je m'adresse à
monsieur le graet c'est à la fédération
française de football il est anormal que
nos joueurs représentent la france ne
sont pas accompagnés par la fédération
française de football c'est un message
fort que je vous lance ma quand je vois
mes joueurs compath protège moi des
joueurs qu'on passe trappe on paye avec
nos fonds propres on n'a pas des de
monsieur le graet donc sincèrement c'est
un sos je vous lance alors derrière ce
message il ya beaucoup de choses moi je
vous demande de nous recevoir nous
mettre autour d'une table et parlons
parlons pour l'intérêt général des
personnes amputées qui pratiquent ce
sport là en france
donc mon rituel je commence toujours par
le pied droit et je termine pas pied
gauche
le pied gauche
aujourd'hui on va tout donner on va
vraiment tout tout tout donné là
aujourd'hui on a pas on n'a pas le droit
à l'erreur c'est aurélie doit gagner si
on gagne on vendait des finales même
temps 1 0
on va en demi finale et voilà ça va être
ça va être ça en valait au delà de
monique
le couple élève de match dresser dans le
calcio en direct
j'ai pris un carton jaune et je le
regarde comme ça toi je suis énervé tu
vois et deux secondes après j'étais tout
coule il m'a envoyé des photos le mode
coach énervé quand je coule tu es
incroyable quand il faisait changer toi
la can la patate on lâche pas on joue on
arrache on les mange on se qualifie on
se retrouve à 18 heures pour une autre
interview
[Musique]
on joue au ballon n'a rien à perdre
aujourd'hui on perdre 3 0 on va jouer
maintenant on repart comme ça je vais
changer d'ici trois minutes de système
de jeu allait en place qu'un garçon on a
besoin de toi mais tu as une volonté qui
est extraordinaire d'accord on va
changer moi même je te faire passer - m
je voulais je mette en sentinelle à la
place de nabil je compte sur toi oui je
compte sur toi je compte sur toi mon
gars sont d'accord allez
mais flamme olympique le monde y est
attaché ni pour me no 9 du métro
59% à trop gâcher spots crânien ses
pieds de lucho chez peak n'ai pas
l'habitude mais cech et saronni comme
j'ai certes écoulée mais comme ils ont
bloqué et que tous les objets dans ta
banane à tous crins photo joe
cole et d'accès nous et d'imams et blake
est allé ce capital et tout a été là
ça fait 5
situation
finalement ressemblé sur
[Musique]
des jeux de deux manches de transparence
important que les dames les derniers
on aurait élevé peut-être au niveau de
jeu on aurait peut-être quelque chose
mais après il ya une réalité en tout cas
une chose est sûre c'est qu'on a 4e
match match de classement on finira pas
dernier ça c'est sûr on va finir
peut-être dans les cinq premiers merci à
vous tous bravo et on continue comme ça
en résulter
c'est pas mal bourlingué comme on dit en
région parisienne j'ai pas ses 500
matchs de foot j'ai vécu par matt damon
pas mal de choses mais
cette situation-là cette expérience là
n'existe pas j'ai pas vu ça incroyable
moi je suis choqué et nous on fait un
beau temps dit kb c'est une deuxième vie
et moi je vous remercie tous deux stars
si vous gagnez contre la géorgie la
prime malheureusement les sera
légèrement les soirs à 200 euros pour
tous les joueurs par peur par joueur se
contente
d'un bon d'achat de 100 euros à un
castor
voilà
[Musique]
bien sûr littéralement
amusez vous c'est beau parcours
à nous amuser nouvelle assez mal cher
a study jasper je veux marquer au moins
un but comme ça je vais le dédicacer à
ma fille ce qu'elle nous demande souvent
à ce que j'ai marqué
je suis muet
je vous ai faite récemment
je me suis jamais
[Musique]
on joue sur des terrains annexes en
général ça vient vraiment plaisir on
dirait de la moquette vous pourrez même
jouer au golf de si je crois excellent
gouvernement plaisir
vous pouvez changer
[Applaudissements]
on arrive au penalty voilà maintenant la
carte qui nous fasse on verra qui
gagnera en tout cas moi je suis fier de
vous bravo à vous allez les gars
vous c'est un entraînement voix
saluée à droite
[Musique]
si elle tape le poteau de l'arrière mais
poteau derrière un poteau el tri mais
thierry
regarde une fois la cage et tu la lune
il ya trois mètres on à l'entraînement
là y'a rien je ne tiendra
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces deux poteaux ça arrive
ouais
may arago écoutent écouter public
[Musique]
c'est un moment
c'est marx et bekar clip ici
[Musique]
ne le regarde pas et quartiers à l'épée
qui
peut durer une grosse frappe juste eu la
cades
à
[Applaudissements]
j'ai réussi j'ai marqué c'est un film
intime et
ça fait plaisir là on était là sa
cinquième pour une première ça fait
plaisir
[Applaudissements]
lorsque mon enfance tous les moments
conçu par au stade
l'habitude supporter à la suis joueur et
ça fait ça fait vraiment plaisir je suis
content / sipa foot en tout avec un
coach extraordinaire mi coéquipiers ou
sais quoi du bonheur
[Musique]